curry brown aldridge and the rookie
thomas
[Applause]
[Music]
thomas trying to get free can go in the
back court and gets it
they're going to flatten out instead of
run
a pick and roll
thomas long three-pointer puts it in cam
thomas from way downtown oh what a shot
from the rookie
and brooklyn goes up by six with 6.8
remaining
what a fluff quarter for cam thomas
and the pain for the knick fans here at
madison square garden
16 points for thomas in the final period
young fella got it going they flatten it
out 1-4
no pick and roll just you and me
cam
oh cam flat out getting it done putting
on a clinic in the fourth quarter
putting his team on his back and making
every right play mama there goes that
man
again he was two for 11 after three
quarters struggling with a shot
but has hit seventh field goes in with a
fourth for 16 points
and another 20-point game for thomas
what a stretch he's been on
a rookie from lsu i mean and look at the
talent to be able to get your own shot
the finishes
the pull-ups
[Music]
bourne squirrel
and he's got that lift on the pull-up
that gives him the high release
and the ability to shoot over
bigger players but this one
the dagger
well he had that 30 point game at utah
this one just 21 but so many big buckets
and the knicks fans here in the garden
can't believe it nets on the verge of
one of the great comebacks
in franchise history down 28 in the
first half down 18 here in the fourth
quarter
[Music]
perks to fournier
fournier puts up the three-pointer
that's good 3.7 remaining
knicks are out of timeouts though
they've got to come up with a steal
[Music]
and steve nash will call a timeout to
advance the ball
with 3.7 remaining and here aldridge
with a chance to seal it
all he's going to do is make one
[Applause]
and that will do it
[Music]
this can be a galvanizing
spike lead that's seen
too many of these type of home games
the knicks but this could be a
galvanizing win for the nets no question
they've got a positive outlook with the
trade and the new players